now that Marvel Studios has confirmed
that Maher Sheela Ali will lead the
blade reboot as Eric Brooks artists and
Photoshop experts have created edits and
illustrations imagining what Ali could
look like as a daywalker here's a
glimpse at some of the best using a
poster of Maher Sheela Ali as a devious
vector and Alisa battle angel artist
Missouri official whipped up a cool idea
of what the actor might look like as
blade Ali's blade rocks black sunglasses
and an old black suit holding a massive
sword ready to slice and dice any
vampires that come his way also inspired
by Maher Sheela Ali's performances
vector and elites of battle angel
popular digital artist and Photoshop
master boss logic created an edit of
what the Oscar winner could look like as
blade we can't say what's more
impressive boss logics work or that he
created the edit five months before Ali
was announced as the new blade are you
from the future
yeah kid I know well that's brilliant
did they still have sandwiches there
when Marvel announced that a blade
reboot was happening with Ali taking the
lead as Eric Brooks Goldie otha got to
work illustrating some seriously
stunning concept art and shared the
results on her Instagram perilous
trations to pick dollies played in a
full costume and with fangs with a
close-up shots of him looking head-on at
the camera with red sunglasses our fur
also shared a standalone version of the
front-facing illustration in digital
artist Monta has us guys rendition of
Mahalo Ali's blade the character wears
his hair in a high-top fade style that
shows off his head and neck tattoos and
holds his weapon of choice gracefully in
his hand against a deep red background
blade looks determined a time hardened
and totally badass
exactly Omar rios imagines that when
maja Sheila Ali takes the play to become
the new Eric Brooks you'll get more than
just his hands dirty on his Instagram
page
ozone seven one nine Rios shed a full
color and the black-and-white
illustration that shows Ali's played
with multiple weapons and a bulletproof
vest that's covered in blood
another person who predicted Marvel
Studios would cast Maher Sheila Ali as a
famous daywalker bus artist and
illustrator Masood Zahir uploading his
striking original artwork on his
Instagram master gram Tahir shed an
eye-catching black and red so
illustration of what Ali could look like
when he makes his Marvel Cinematic
Universe debut it's bound to put a smile
on anyone's face on his Instagram
account Ultra roar 26 your vendor Singh
Rana made a piece of art that shows all
he's played with an intense look on his
face staring someone down from behind
red lens glasses as he reaches for the
weapon on his back if that doesn't
scream played we don't know what does
artist kami viale imagine that Mahalo
our leads that are aged in the blade
will hold nothing back in the
forthcoming reboots on her Instagram
account CBL ayaats pla shared her vision
of the actor and the role kneeling on
the ground wearing a smug smirk on his
face as enemies aim their weapons
directly at his chest shoulder and leg
it's easy to imagine him getting ready
to devastate his enemies with a perfect
one-liner you know something like
someone's always trying to mesh de
Tocqueville Empire design art director
Ally Gibbs took an O so sleek approach
with his artwork depicting what my her
Sheila Ali might look like as blade on
his Twitter against a bright red
background
Ali's blade looks dramatically to his
right while resting his gun against his
shoulder and neck
Jackson caspere's created a beautiful
illustration of Maher Sheila aleeah's
blade while a number of enemies lurk in
the background the picture appears to
depict a scene just seconds before an
awesome rooftop vampire fight scene one
where the vampires learn a very
important lesson
worse things out tonight than vampires
[Music]
artists apex former so impressed with
Ali's casting as blade that they created
an ultra cool edit in which Ali's
version of blade has red eyes two blades
on his back and loads of tattoos
whatever Ollie's blade looks like in the
upcoming film one thing's for sure you
tell them is helping Susan and horse
games check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
but your favorite films are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]